und bei uns ist so gene experte dr klaus
dieter zastrow im studio schönen tag
hallo ja ist das die richtige strategie
boostern für alle
jedenfalls gibt es im moment gar keine
hinweise dafür denn wir kennen zum
beispiel nicht die die schwellen die
antikörper
grenzen ab denen dann praktisch der
impfschutz entfallen würde die die
informationen gibt es noch nicht ist als
sie liegen wissenschaftliche eigentlich
noch nicht vor und deswegen kann man
auch gar nicht sagen dass du in jeder
eine dritte impfung bräuchte und
muss natürlich auch wissen oder auch
eigentlich dazu sagen dass diese so
genannten impft durchbrüche das heißt
bei den geimpften eigentlich immer leute
mit entsprechenden risikofaktoren sind
beziehungsweise mit vorerkrankung also
ich habe noch von keinem
kerngesunden gehört dass der imf
durchbruch hatte es war immer
tumorbehandlung immunsupprimierten durch
was auch immer selbst ein
allergiker der das ganze jahr kortison
nimmt ist natürlich schon in der abwehr
geschwächt
und
diabetiker und übergewichtige wenn man
genauer nachfragt da stellt sich so was
alles heraus und für die und natürlich
auch das hohe alter gilt natürlich auch
als eine gewisse abwehrschwäche und da
ist es natürlich auf jeden fall richtig
aber das ist nur ein 35-jähriger noch
der dritte impfung braucht die
notwendigkeit die überhaupt nicht da
sollte man sich lieber auf die
konzentrieren die sie wirklich brauchen
aber sie haben es gesagt es geht vor
allem auch um die antikörper sollte man
nicht irgendwas entwickeln was mal
schnell die antikörper testen lässt wo
wir dann auch wissen so und so viel ist
mein wert ich kann also ganz frei raus
gehen und alle freiheiten genießen ja
das wäre schön wenn wir das hätten haben
wir aber noch nicht dazu ist die
impfungen natürlich auch noch zu jung
wir haben das bei anderen impfungen bei
der hepatitis b schutzimpfung da war es
nämlich am anfang auch so 1984 als
dieser ausgabe 84 85 da hat man gesagt
alle sechs monate muss angeben und so
hat man festgestellt die antikörper sind
hoch genug inzwischen sind wir bei zehn
jahren abstand aber das können wir
natürlich für diese impfung noch nicht
sagen aber da muss natürlich gearbeitet
werden aber diese alarmstimmung dass die
gesamte bevölkerung nur dritter impfung
brauch dass das ist falscher alarm
antikörper ich habe selber schon ein
gemacht ja einfach kurze blutabnahme am
nächsten tag kennt man den wert haben
sie recht ich habe es auch schon gemerkt
kenne meinen wert auch aber keiner kann
ihnen sagen ab wann ist denn jetzt
eigentlich schluss ja
ich sag jetzt mal ein paar 0 du hast
jetzt 200 ja
und wenn du 180 hast dann brauchst du
unbedingt eine impfung ja oder ob man
sagen kann bei 200
ist alles bestens dass das wissen wir
eben noch nicht
damit kommen natürlich auch zum thema
testen das ja auch wieder aktuell
vor drei wochen wurden die kostenlosen
tests abgeschafft und man hat gesehen
dass sich tatsächlich immer weniger
menschen testen lassen sowohl ungeimpfte
als auch geimpfte weil die tests ja
durchaus auch teuer sind bis zu 25 euro
damit sollte der druck auf die
ungeimpften ausgeübt werden die
statistik sagt aber gleichzeitig auch
dass nur 600.000 menschen sich in dieser
zeit also erwachsene sich haben impfen
lassen das funktioniert also offenbar
nicht sollte man zum schutz aller die
kostenlosen tests wieder einführen ja
natürlich also der vorschlag jetzt von
2g ja also das heißt ja geimpft und
genesen und dazu geht ja das 3g und da
sind die getesteten als der test muss
natürlich dazu kommen und schon alleine
deshalb wir sind den ganzen sommer über
das ist ja den ganzen sommer über
wunderbar mit den test zurechtgekommen
und
die genauso die preispolitik ist
eigentlich ein unding dass das 20 30
euro wie sie schon gesagt haben gekostet
der test kostet 185 oder oder oder oder
nur
60 cent je nachdem wo man und dass da
jetzt sagen wir mal von startseite nicht
dass vorgegeben wird und dass man sagt
also wir machen es umsonst oder für 150
das ist mir völlig unverständlich also
beziehungsweise an sich ist das ja
völlig klar man versucht die leute zur
impfung zu bewegen aber das wird so
nicht funktionieren aber die machen dann
und dann haben wir beides nicht die
impfung nicht und auch den test nicht
mehr also das ist ein ganz schlechtes
signal
und wie gesagt wir sind mit den tests
gut zurechtgekommen die sind auch
akzeptiert von den leuten und dass man
die jetzt gerade unter der
berücksichtigung weihnachten
weihnachtsmärkte und
auch wo es ein bisschen enger wird dass
man die jetzt auf einmal praktisch
unmöglich heute wieder in rückstand der
neuinfizierten über
37.000 an einem tag ist das auch ein
grund dafür dass die tests nicht mehr
kostenlos sind und die leute sie einfach
nicht mit ja ich habe ich habe auch an
meine zweifel ob diese zahlen überhaupt
stimmen also diese 37.000 weil wir ganz
heimlich still und leise in einem papier
aus dem juli
21 finden dass ab sofort die
krankenhäuser auch die verdachtsfälle
melden ja das heißt also wir da hat
jemand hustet und ein bisschen schnupfen
und dann sagte einer könnte corona sein
um schon ist er drin ja
und das ist natürlich ein das gilt zwar
nur für die krankenhäuser aber die
krankenhäuser haben natürlich eine
vielzahl von patienten und und männer
und ziehen sehen auch die patienten die
nach einer stunde wieder nach hause
gehen also ob das ob das alles so genau
was und außerdem ist dann noch die frage
wie schwer ist denn derjenige der sich
jetzt bei mir vorstellt erkrankt hat ein
bisschen kopfschmerzen oder muss ja
schon beatmet werden ja und da gibt es
ja eine riesige spanne da halte ich die
zahl also sowieso uns jetzt präsentiert
wird ist sie nur zur panik machen können
wir jetzt natürlich nicht überprüfen auf
die schnelle herr zastrow jetzt ist
natürlich auch die frage im raum ob
nicht alle getestet werden sollten da
wir ja gesehen haben dass eben auch
geimpfte durchaus infizieren können oder
infiziert sein können oder es auch
weitertragen können steht die frage im
raum sollte man grundsätzlich alle
testen um ins restaurant zu kommen
beispielsweise um ins kino gehen zu
können wir haben uns mal auf der straße
umgehört
in hannover was die leute dazu sagen man
ist sozusagen eine art 1g regelung gebe
finde ich super perfekt war ja auch
geimpfte anstecken können also finde ich
sehr gut
ich setze mich auch obwohl ich geben ich
halte davon nichts da ich einfach der
meinung bin wir haben alle dieselben
rechte egal ob geimpft oder nicht er 80
persönlich als sehr sinnvoll auf weil ja
auch selbst kämpfte menschen das virus
weitergeben können und ich finde dass
wir dadurch auch der spaltung der
gesellschaft den gegen ein gs blitze
verkehrt ist das nicht ganz mit dem
testen mit viel und der läuterung
vorstellt der sollte sich zwischendurch
auch mal testen lassen meine frau die
macht mich schon verrückt mit diesem
blödsinn ich bin zweimal geimpft und ich
kümmere mich da nicht darum ehrlich wer
auf jeden fall vernünftig wenn du noch
getestete menschen an veranstaltungen
teilnehmen können und die die hatte
empfohlen sind was ist mit den
ressourcen
die müssen sich noch mal testen lassen
ja was halten sie von einer regelung
manche bürger haben das ja richtig
gesagt er sagte ich bin zweimal geimpft
und damit ist für mich die sache
erledigt und genau so muss es auch sein
wir können doch jetzt nicht hingehen und
sagen wir vertrauen der impfung nicht ja
wir haben auf die der impfung entgegen
gehechelt sie ist auch gefeiert worden
sieht es auch geprüft also da kommt ja
nicht irgendwas aus blauen dunst und und
was die politik da macht dass sie jetzt
auch die noch die wirksamkeit der
impfung in frage stellt wo inzwischen
650 millionen bürger geimpft worden sind
das ist ja geradezu bescheuert denn
sehen sie wir haben 56 millionen die im
von den unseren zähle jetzt noch 16
millionen aber gleichzeitig wird gesagt
aber die impfung so richtig wird sie
jedoch nicht wir müssen ja doch noch mal
testen das ist doch idiotisch es wäre
auch total schwierig dies umzusetzen ein
ge alle müssen sich beweisen dann müsste
es definitiv wieder kostenlos werden
müsste es dann auch einen pcr-test
seiner ginge dann auch ein schnelltest
das sind halt alles fragen die dann
gehen wir sind ja mit das war ja am
anfang immer pc oder schnell dass er hat
mein schmerz stellte es wird immer
besser ja und dann sind
dabei auch geblieben und und das reicht
eigentlich auch ja aber wir können doch
jetzt nicht ernsthaft alles das was wir
praktisch die letzten zwölf monate auch
mit einem gewissen erfolg gemacht haben
wieder in frage stellen und sagen
hat sie impfen lassen ist auch sehr
schild gegner ja wenn wenn wenn du
sollst nicht impfen lassen und dann
sagen wir aber kann immer noch sein ja
da sagte er na siehste warum soll ich
mich impfen lassen also dass keine frage
die jetzt sozusagen damit im raum steht
wenn die dritte impfung kommen muss ab
wann ist man eigentlich wirklich
vollständig geimpft ist man nach zwei
impfungen gar nicht mehr vollständig
geimpft nach dem interview mit helge
braun wo wir vor den ausschnitte gesehen
haben haben wir das
gesundheitsministerium mal angefragt und
haben ganz konkrete fragen gestellt und
zwar haben wir gefragt was bedeutet
jetzt noch vollständig geimpft gelten
ältere die im januar geimpft worden auch
jetzt noch als vollständig geimpft und
wenn ja wie lange noch da kam vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium allerdings
keine klare antwort stattdessen auf alle
bild fragen nur diese knappen
komplizierten setzte an der definition
des impfstatus hat sich nichts geändert
die serie für corona impfungen ist
abhängig vom impfstoff mit zeitlicher
distanz zu ersten oder zweiten impfung
abgeschlossen auffrischimpfungen helfen
aber den impfschutz zu verbessern eine
antwort mit der sie so klackern ja dass
genau das ist es also wir haben von
anfang an vom hersteller gewusst wir
brauchen also zwei impfungen und
nach ein paar wochen haben wir dann
antichrist aufgebaut werden haben wir
dann einen vollständigen impfschutz also
absolut richtig und
alles andere was da kam eben auch noch
und mehr kann man eben auch nicht sagen
und es gibt aber auch gar keinen grund
das zu bezweifeln ja und das viele haben
natürlich jetzt angst durch diese hohen
zahlen die er natürlich auch jeder hat
das ist richtig aber diese
33.000 die da jetzt gekommen sind oder
35.000 37.000 heute das sind doch nicht
geimpfte ja das sind leute die ihm nicht
geimpfte hat der spanier recht dass er
sagt das ist dann eben von mir aus die
familie und ist aber egal wir haben doch
nicht 37.000 geimpfte leute die nun auf
einmal alle wieder erkranken das ist
blödsinn etwas über 16 millionen
menschen sind in deutschland noch nicht
geimpft naja aber wir hatten im vorigen
jahr hatten wir 80 millionen ungeimpfte
ja und jetzt auf einmal sollen wir mehr
haben
als im vorigen jahr wo wir jetzt rund 60
millionen schon geimpft haben also
irgendwas stimmt da nicht letzte frage
ganz kurz noch im neuen
ard-deutschlandtrend befürchten 57
prozent der deutschen dass es neue
einschränkungen gibt und dann wenig
verwunderlich 57 prozent der deutschen
also eine klare mehrheit sind inzwischen
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht in
deutschland was sagen sie dazu ja gut
das ist wirklich eine echte politische
frage
ich persönlich bin ein freund des
impfens und halte das auch für die beste
methode den infektionskrankheiten
beizukommen das haben wir bei pocken
geschafft bei tuberkulose
das heißt in frage die großen solchen
der vergangenheit sind in erster linie
natürlich durch hygiene also impfpflicht
ja oder nein
also letztendlich also ich sag mal im
moment sehe ich noch keinen wirklichen
grund wir haben hier nicht heerscharen
von leichen die irgendwo auf der straße
liegen das heißt also die leute
gelesen auch teilweise merken sie nicht
mal dass die positiv sind da halte ich
dann das doch für für etwas verfrüht
wenn man sich die situation tatsächlich
in diese ernste
krankheitsverlauf überall dann wird man
es wahrscheinlich machen müssen ja aber
dann werden vielleicht auch die leute
selber noch
zur vernunft kommen aber der impfstoffe
sind sicher da kann uns sowieso nichts
passieren